Alex Cohen and Dimitri zakarov do
fantastic this designs from MIT Dima he
probably met already I like
unfortunately didn't make it here uh so
the the topic is the Hebron triangle
problem uh some recent developments and
I'll start uh gentle by introducing the
problem say say some things about the
history and uh
the some of the ideas that motivated the
the new result so what is this problem
given a natural number n
one can ask about the following quantity
what is the smallest function Delta
Delta of n such that in every
configuration of endpoints and the unit
Square there always exists a triangle of
area at most Delta so Delta uh smallest
area that you can find in every
configuration so let's let's uh get the
sense of what what this function is for
small small numbers uh when n equals
four this this uh so we have four points
in the Square what's for the smallest
area always you can find a triangular
area at most one half and this this can
be seen immediately by just splitting up
the picture into two triangles uh it
doesn't really matter if the four points
are in convex position or concave
position they always can run something
the the two triangles have disjoint
interiors and the full area of the
squares one definitely one one timer one
half
uh this is also one half is also the
smallest number for which the sentence
is true you should take the corners of
the square and definitely uh all the
triangles have area uh one half so you
cannot really improve on this quantity
uh so it's like like many other
functions the next email combinatorics
it's it's uh
hard to determine its values for small
uh and also here are some pictures so
long from uh
with the HTML configurations the best
the best known configurations for a
small n so uh for n equals five I think
the answer is known for n equals six uh
it's also no starting with n at least
seven I think these are just the best
known and they're not matching upper
bounds
so pictures look the fact that it helps
all sorts of symmetry but kind of hard
to to understand what what are the
patterns
uh what about uh larger configurations
so kind of the story starts with the
remarkable construction of erdosch from
the early 60s maybe before in writing
it's from the 50s so one can construct a
set of endpoints in the unit Square so
that all the triangles have area at
least the constant times 1 over n Square
so uh the construction is uh is
algebraic it's by pretty essentially
it's a very scaled modular Parabola so
the idea is that if you take points on
uh on the parabola there's no trick
linear so in particular if you take the
set of points X over p y over P where p
is a prime between n into n uh where X
and Y range from 0 to P minus 1 and Y is
x squared so this these are
some points in the unit Square after
this rescaling still don't have three
collinear and uh and the triangles have
large area because well the dilate of
this picture can dilate by P is a is a
configuration of points that have
integer coordinates and and uh the area
of a triangle with integer coordinates
it's at least one half so the area of
any triangle determined by three where
the season X
must must be at least one over two times
this the scaling Factor P Squared and
so this this is at least a constant
times 1 over n Square given the choice
of P
so this is a this is a nice construction
and it's not really the only
construction so it's possible to
construct configurations with all
triangles a very at least the constants
one over N squared probabilistically one
can take endpoints at random and delete
really uh one one vertex from each
triangle that has an area of uh area at
most one one over N squared and if one
analyzes this uh deletion argument uh
rather straightforwardly you still get
the construction matching the same
quantitative Bond so possible to do the
greedy construction choosing endpoints
gradually also leads to a configuration
with the same feature and so it was uh
this this aspect of the problem that
motivated in the late 40s early 50s to
conjecture that maybe maybe this this
one over n Square should be the correct
order of the magnitude for the problem
so uh maybe it's true that there are
some absolute constants little CM Dixie
so that this function is between these
two expressions
however they start out to be false uh so
rather famously in in the early 80s uh
komblosh pins and semeridi uh managed to
construct endpoints in the unit Square
such that all the triangles have area at
least one over in square times and
factor of log
and uh this uh it's an important result
the proof is one of the highlights still
one of the highlights of the simulator
method in extreme combinatorics it's a
random construction like the deletion
one that I described earlier but the
analysis a bit more careful so it
involves results about independence
numbers in uh three uniform four in
three uniform hypergraphs that are
locally sparse
um of course since well it's a disproof
of a conjecture that's just by a factor
of log as it happens uh air Dosh
conjectured immediately right after that
uh okay maybe the correct conjecture is
with log log of n Over N squared and
this uh this test Still Remains of the
Day an open problem
um
okay today's talk will be however about
upper bounds so let's let's switch gears
and and instead of trying to construct
configurations with all triangles having
large areas let's start with an
arbitrary configuration and ask okay
what's a small area triangle that I can
always find there
uh so let's start somewhere with with an
easy bound and give you any end points
uh I claim there's always a triangle of
area at most one over n several ways to
do this I won't dwell too much
you just fix a point and draw triangles
from it to the rest so you can draw n
minus two
triangles that have disjoint Interiors
it takes from a vertex
and uh well again they add up the total
area is up to something at most one and
there's a triangular area one over n
minus two
so this is this is nice and easy there
as I said there are other ones
um however perhaps what's maybe
surprising if if you're seeing this
problem for the first time
it's not easy at all to improve upon
this uh easy estimate in fact uh here's
a quick challenge uh I'll leave you 30
seconds or a minute can you find maybe a
triangle a very little of one over n so
just a little bit better
Allah try to procrastinate telling you
the next next step of the story by maybe
uh drawing your attention towards some
important geometric facts that we'll use
today so uh what's the most important
fact I will use today area of a triangle
is half
times the base times the height of the
triangle
in particular
this leads to the following nice
observation if I'm interested in small
area triangles let's say triangles of
area at most a and I fix two vertices of
my configuration X and Y well the set of
Point Z in the plane that form a
triangle with X and Y are very utmost a
is uh uh a strip whose width I can
understand because of this area formula
so it's it's a width it's a strip
centered
on this line supporting the the pair X Y
that has width four times a divided by
the length of the segment x minus one
uh
well here's here's here's an immediate
corollary in the in the context of the
hillbrow triangle problem if if Delta
denotes this quantity the smallest area
that you can find them in your
configuration P of n points if I draw
these strips for every pair of points X
and Y so I have my pair X and Y and I
draw the strip of that width around it
and I do this for every pair
uh this dress must be quite deplete of
points they don't really have anything
else other than X and Y anything inside
here would make a triangle of area less
than Delta uh and Delta by Design is the
smallest area
or something like that for which a
triangle exists so you have these empty
strips there
uh it's okay I think maybe I mean the
past uh
uh
it is possible to improve on this
trivial bounds and this was really
beautiful breakthrough result of root
from the early 50s so he managed to show
that indeed there is a triangle a very
little of one over n
uh the argument uh is a very nice that's
the increment argument that in some
sense starts with this final observation
from the previous slide uh you have
these empty strips around every uh every
pair of points of that width and they
cut out a significant portion of the
area of the square
and so it makes it makes it seems uh
sensible to maybe look at the complement
of these strips inside the square there
are still many points left maybe one can
find a square where there's an increased
density
this strategy is not not easy to
implement at all in fact it doesn't work
at all for squares if if one poses the
problem like this but it's really uh the
beginning of this argument that it's an
argument that should resemble the
other theorem on the maximum size the
set of one up to n without three term
arithmetic progressions in fact this
this result is the precursor of of that
here it only appeared two years earlier
um
I want to say more about the dense
increment argument although it's in some
sense important uh for for uh for us but
a bit more indirectly I will uh move
forward 20 years so not much progress
has been made on on the upper bound side
of the problem until Schmidt in the 70s
who managed to improve on this uh growth
argument which was quite quantitative in
fact the numerology
tantalizingly similar to the the bomb
for Ros theorem about three AP three
sets
just a coincidence uh however
so uh like like this problem uh like
like that problem this one got improved
also so Schmidt in 72 managed to turn
this log double log event into log of N
and the argument uh will represent
really an important moment for this
problem I think also an important moment
for us it's really uh an argument that
kind of sets the right perspective for
this problem namely it's it's it's uh
it's after this paper this problem
becomes really a problem in incidence
geometry so I want to sketch a little
bit this uh what what Smith is doing
um the idea is quite simple I won't
really care too much about going over
the details but at least the setup so
watch me that was the following
um
if uh if uh I started with my set of
points being the unit Square it seems
again very tempting to construct these
uh
these uh these strips for every pair of
points of the of the previous width so
this four times Delta over over the the
length of the segment of the
corresponding pair before I had the four
and now I'm putting a another constancy
to be decided later
it won't really be as important to me
that these strips are empty other than
the generators
um however it's important that the width
is close to that critical threshold
and what Schmidt did was Define an
incidence graph for this problem so uh
you have these strips also uh I will
call them interchangeably tubes and I
can consider the incidence graph between
the sets of points in the unit square
and uh these uh these tubes uh so maybe
I should
so here
the points of the square
the cell will be uh my set of tubes Okay
so
imagine the points here imagine where
the CCR corresponding to these tubes so
this is uh say
generated by the pair how
Swift
distance
the length of the segment between the
two points of the pair and uh it's not
just gonna be a simple incidence graph a
normal incidence graph would be a graph
where I draw an edge between a point and
a square and uh in a tube if the point
is in the tube I'm also going to weight
it appropriately I'm gonna weight it by
the the width of the corresponding strip
it sees on the right okay so I'm gonna
put this uh
c times Delta divided by D of Tau
as a weight for each Edge
any questions about the setup the
notation I think it's a very cute cute
argument so I would like to maybe uh
have it safe
yeah this is a point in the square and
this is a tube it is
if x is uh yeah yeah it's an element
that's that lies in the two exactly
[Music]
okay so kind of the the main observation
although it wasn't really a phrase like
that uh at the time uh is that this
incidence graph has bounded degree if
it's weighted accordingly
so for every at least not on one side
for every for every point in the Square
the the sum of the weights of the
corresponding edges coming out of x
bounded by a constant
sum up these numbers
some of the wages at most one
[Music]
um so this this uh this uh involves some
some
geometric reasoning it's quite uh quite
neat I'm not sure
uh
to what extent I should do it but kind
of the point behind considering these uh
these widths is that if I fix the point
x
uh
tubes through X of that width cannot
really overlap too much in uh
inside the square so if I have here
L but
let's say I have here uh
unit segment
can be one half
say one half
so these are not the generators of these
strips this is just the point x I'm
interested in bounding and controlling
the degree of and uh I claim that I
cannot really have two of these strips
uh sharing X I'm also sharing a point
why that at the constant distance from X
simply because if I put down the
generators with the four strips well
that would mean
um
that there's a small area triangle
between those four generators if I
choose that constant C appropriately the
definition
very easy to check
so uh if that doesn't happen well I have
a picture like this
if I draw a circle with radius one half
X
I have these strips containing X
and they really don't overlap any at
distance one half
so I draw all these strips that contain
X
uh the sum of their widths
must be at most the circumference of the
circle if these strips are disjoint
why there is not a point in
the point in the Square I look at all
the strips containing it the sum of
their widths is bounded by something
involving pi
this is the claim here
districts can intersect the but not uh
so they can intersect somewhere here but
not not too far apart
yeah they cannot intersect though this
is a circle of uh of radius one half
intersection on the boundary would mean
a picture like this it's just just uh
just uh
just a sketch
uh
anyway so uh with something like this
one has a very good understanding of the
number of edges of the graph right uh
like an upper bound number of edges
weighted in a weighted sense by just
summing these degrees and using this
bound and then all one has to do is uh
exchange science so this is something
over all the vertices taking an integral
over all the x's in the Square
exchanging the sum in the integral and
uh the integral of the characteristic
function of a tube right is really the
uh the area that the tube intersects in
the Square so this is uh comes out to be
the sum of the squares of the
corresponding widths and uh this is
bounded by a constant
because the degrees are bounded by a
constant but now the widths here they
involve Delta this this part of the
argument does not really involve Delta
anymore one can extract an upper Bound
for Delta just in terms of this quantity
that is uh the sum of the reciprocals of
the squares of distances over all the
points and and P these quantities have
been studied for a while analysis
they're called risk energies so this is
the Tourist energy or minus two increase
energy depending on who you talk to and
this is at least n Square Times log n
one can prove this without too much
trouble
so that's that's Schmidt's argument as
you see uh it doesn't really use any
sophisticated geometry so the point of
me sharing this is that uh you can maybe
put yourself in our shoes when when we
saw an argument like this we uh
definitely thought that okay maybe it
has been so much advancement in incident
geometry maybe one can use uh more
sophisticated tools from instant to
improve on this argument it seems a bit
unsophisticated to Upper bound the
number of edges in an incidence graph by
upper Bound by using a bond on the
degrees uniform boundary degrees
uh of course Roth also had this idea
before even though there was no
incidence geometry available at the time
uh in fact right after the same year
um
he essentially uh
indirectly invented the whole reinvented
the whole area uh uh this is 10 years
before the summary protar theorem as a
point of reference uh so right after
wrote managed to uh dramatically improve
on this Bond of Schmidt and show that
there's an absolute constant usage that
Delta event is at most this one over n
the power one plus mu so there is a
triangle of uh polynomially smaller area
that then Schmidt was able to find with
this uh this argument I sketched so
um okay
um
rosebound like before was was
quantitative he found an explicit
exponent meal this was this uh this is
this thing that's close to 0.1 uh 0.105
I should maybe say because all of them
are 0.1
um then wrote subsequently wrote the
second paper where he optimized for the
uh several things in the argument
um
getting this this exponent to be 0.117
[Music]
and then uh in 83
Comm launch pins and semi-ready uh
managed to reach a natural limit of
Rod's method showing that you can always
find a triangular area one over n to the
eight over seven
so uh yeah my plan today is to give you
a sense about uh this claim that this is
indeed this 8 over 7 is is a is a
natural limit in in Rosemary in some
sense it's an optimization of of this
method as pre as known up to 83 or later
um
and uh
maybe put this into a slightly different
different perspective
um so our result manages to just uh
break this exponent by a little bit so
and and recent DreamWork with Alex and
Dima we show that there is a triangle of
area uh almost one over this n to the
eight over seven but now you also have a
plus one over two thousand of course
this one over two thousand is not really
uh important on its own we don't really
try too too much to to get the best best
exponent there but it is any exponent
that you can get with our method will be
a small number of that sort yes what is
the next natural barrier I I will I will
maybe discuss some of these things it's
a good question of course
um okay so
um
like beef uh I'd like to tell you about
Rod setup and uh what we do to uh go a
bit beyond what he did however I thought
it would be maybe a good moment to take
a break between uh uh with with points
and strips for for another to three
minutes and maybe discuss a little bit
uh
some product phenomenon and projection
Theory because our result this exponent
uh it's funny shape uh is an
manifestation of organized discretized
and product theorem so uh and uh
that's implicitly and explicitly it
comes from recent developments and
projection Theory
so I would like to tell you about the
these two things I know this is the
mixed audience I know there are many
people in additive competitors here that
are very familiar with some product
phenomena however I won't really talk
about maybe the standard some product
question due to air dozen similarity
from the 80s I will go even uh more back
to uh the first question of this nature
as far as I know by erdosch who was
interested I think all of his life in in
some product type questions uh so this
is a question of erdogs involtman and I
think really
um started started this business a
really beautiful question that I wish I
knew maybe uh earlier in my life so I
wanted to share it
um uh so what what they asked was the
following uh is there any Boreal
measurable suffering of the real numbers
that has intermediate Dimension so
Dimension between zero and one uh the
notion that I mentioned that uh will be
everywhere present today will be house
door Dimension I won't really Define it
for you because it's a technical
definition won't really be important so
I will just maybe say some examples
instead so the rational numbers is the
suburbing to to have in mind that has
house door Dimension zero the set of
real numbers has house their Dimension
One and this question is about is there
other any other interesting ring in
between the rationals and the real
numbers it has some the dimension that's
between strictly zero and one
yeah so this is an excellent question
this is why the the answer to that
question has to do with why we add this
morale if we remove Borel there are
indeed uh examples that are you can use
Axiom of choice and construct something
pathological that's not very interesting
so that's that's why arduation woman
added
um I did Borel uh if you don't like this
formulation uh so so uh imprecise you
can ask you can think okay what about
think pick your favorite number between
0 and 1. uh like one half or log two
over log three I say locked over log
three because I want I want to give you
another example so take for instance uh
so what what else is there right other
than rationalism
and your numbers think about the middle
third Contour set for example
so that's a that's a set with uh
with Dimension log 2 over log three uh I
want uh I must
I think most of you are familiar with
that I only draw it I just want to uh
maybe I'll draw one one layer below and
you continue to take the intersection of
all of them
um why am I mentioning this so it's not
really a good candidate automatically to
be a suffering of the real numbers of
course if you had two numbers in the
counter set that are closer to the
endpoint here well the sum will escape
this but it seems conceivable right that
uh if you take translates of this
Contour set you cover the real line with
with the set you can maybe make it uh
closed under addition you can even make
it close under the multiplication so
this is really the spirit of this
question can you do can you come come up
with a sub ring from from a counter-like
object like that so it's really
beautiful question and it turns out uh
deeper a bit even deeper than it looks
it was settled famously in the negative
by uh Edgar and Miller in 2003 using
Mars trans projection theorem uh so
marceland projection theorem is the
statement that so it's it's really uh a
work that's Again part of a very
influential paper in in analysis really
started the whole area there's another
day as projection Theory so this is an
area that studies dimensions of
projections of fractals uh so the first
thing that you can ask when you put
those words together is okay I give you
a a set in in R2 that's Boreal again to
avoid the
pathologies and you look at the
projections of a set uh in in in various
directions so let's take a
generic Direction
Teta I project my set on to onto this
line through the origin and that has
angle Theta
what what can I say about the dimension
of this projection definitely does not
grow projection is this map so
that cannot increase the dimension but
what's remarkable is that the dimension
of the projection actually matches
the dimension of the original set for
almost every direction so this is a
really nice result and even more if you
know that the set is more than one
dimensional to begin with then uh
uh the projection even has positive
measure so it's not just that it will
have Dimension one you can say something
a bit more
so uh this was also proved famously by
Borgen with a much more complicated
proof He was unaware of the work by
eduardia Miller the paper came up
roughly at the same time uh he was
motivated by a set of conjectures or
cuts and towel
that are stated like this very
articulately in the paper it's one of my
favorite papers so I had to like uh put
it like that
so what the cutting Tao studied in this
paper was a series of conjecture related
to this uh Heritage World modern
conjecture uh that seemed to be quite
related to each other so these
conjectures and I only put the fullest
but these are Falconer the distance that
conjecture in particular the the
statement that if I have a compact set
in R2 let's say nice set in R2 it has
Dimension at least one and you look at
the set of distinct distances
as a set of the real numbers the set of
this thing distance has Dimension at
least one half plus some constant
uh so this this is a particular case of
the falconer distanced conjecture uh
there's also the first Embark set
problem this is related to continuous
versions of summary throttle theorem
also kakea theorem conjecture sorry
um so this uh particular statement is
that half wustenburg sets have Dimension
at least one plus C have first number
that means a set in R2 nice set again it
has this feature that for every
direction there's a line that hits the
set in a half dimensional set at least
so and it's a claim about such a set
must be large
um so what cuts intoau approved in this
paper is that these certain discretized
version of this continuous statements
are all equivalent to each other
and uh in this alternate proof of uh of
uh Marine conjecture managed to show
this discretized versions thus improving
uh the discretized version of these that
imply The Continuous versions
I am mentioning this because uh like I
like I said uh
this this uh discretize some product
here has been since connected to many
different other parts of mathematics and
today uh essentially talking about
another another topic that has been
affected by by this theorem so let me
get back to the heelbron triangle
problem
uh mentioned this incident setup that's
behind this polynomial improvements and
what does it have to do with projection
Theory
so uh the setup is the following I
started my set of points and um okay I
want to find
uh
small area triangle so again the area
formula is my friend uh I know that it
would be good if I find pairs of points
that are close to each other and it'll
be great if when I draw tubes generated
by those pairs of points uh tubes of a
certain width W if I can catch some
point that's different from the
generators in that tube then well I know
I will have found a triangle that has
area U times W essentially up to
constants so it seems uh
very sensible to Define uh the following
incidence count so I will for a
parameter u i take all the lines passing
through the pairs the distance at most U
and I Define the the number of
incidences between the points p in my
original configuration and the tubes
generated by L that have uh with w
[Music]
okay
um so concretely uh what I said earlier
if I can show that the number of
incidences between these points and
tubes uh is at least two times the
number of lines for a certain choice of
parameter
wfw final then this uh I will have found
an additional incidence a non-trivial
incidence a point that lies in in a new
new tube of with W final
giving me an upper Bound for Delta so
that's kind of the basic the basic
strategy and uh what was the Rod's uh
take on this pre incidence geometry days
so he said okay let's pick two different
skills two different parameters for w
for this this width and uh let's try to
do the following it would be great if I
can start with some maybe more modest
with initial width W sub I for which I
know for sure there are many incidences
many meaning as you would expect if the
num if the set of points and the set of
lines were uniformly at random in in the
in the square in this case tubes with W
sub I would have uh they expect the
number of points in them would be W sub
I times B the number of points in the
Square so uh it would be nice if I can
find uh an initial estimate of that
nature
and then for some smaller more refined
scale W sub f
maybe I can show that the normalized
incidence count uh at scale W final does
not change too much from the normalized
incidence count as klw initial
and if I have these two of course I can
uh
repeat and hope to find the smallest WS
of f for which I still find incidences
at some later scale yes
a lot of practice
um yes
actually the same notation here I
apologize it's not too important but
let's let's uh let's say these are the
same
first one these are all they go they go
and big gamma I apologize yes thank you
don't think this big WF this lesson
lesson there is is not constant or is it
oh this will end up being with not just
yeah it would be much smaller than
nobody so right so you should think for
the record
let's close the constant the function
event is supposed to constant and this
this it will be your aim for something
small the second lesson is bigger over
the first one yeah but for now you can
just think about this
it's a smaller scale
um and uh it's a rough strategy nothing
is already done yet uh so what the
picture kind of looks like this you have
these hopefully tubes with W Supply that
have several points and then the hope
will be to find some W sub F where the
tubes still generate by the Same by the
same lines but thinner will still have
plenty of incidences
um
so uh
like I was saying this was not really
stated at all in terms of
um uh incidences at the time
um wrote was I mean there's an analytic
number here is he uh proved an
inequality that kind of served the
purpose of of what this one is
describing using
the celebration acquired quality so
inspired by the LA receive uh type
inequalities from number Theory uh so it
was more of an L2 kind of relation
between between these normalized counts
I won't really get too much into that
um
uh I will maybe state things directly uh
the way we think about them so our first
maybe uh contribution is that we kind of
rephrase rods
approach regarding the inductive step as
a more modern in terms of a more modern
kind of development and harmonic
analysis called the high low method this
was introduced by good solo more than
one in uh in 2019 which is again roughly
the same thing uh but uh
serving maybe you know one one
formulation might seem more natural to
them to some than than to others
um so I'll talk a little bit about this
and then uh
number two is our main contribution
which is a new approach regarding the
initial estimate which comes from uh
Direction set estimates from projection
Theory so um
so far maybe I should mention here maybe
so far all these uh
polynomial Improvement starting with Rod
ending with convolution similarity uh
optimized improved and finally optimized
the inductive step and all relied on the
same initial estimate input that goes
back to Road's original paper
and uh so our gain ultimately will come
from an improvement
or step a
[Music]
okay
um
so let me talk a little bit about uh
the inductive step first so the
inductive step and the high low method I
remind you briefly the setup so I have
this incidence configuration from before
and two skills some W final less than W
initial uh I would like to stay more
precisely inequality that relates the
normalized incidence count at one scale
with normalized incidence on that
another scale uh it's uh the following
so the absolute value of the difference
is almost a constant times this
expression that involves uh two new
quantities so for a given scale W and P
of w is the maximum number of points
that you see in W by W Square maximum
number of points from p
and that you see in the configuration
and mL of w this is the maximum number
of uh of lines that you see in the in uh
the W by one tube I should perhaps
clarify here when I say that that the
line is contained in a w by one tube I
don't really care about the full line I
only care about its intercept on the
Square so I care about where the line
intersects the square in that portion
I'm interested in how many of those
intercepts lie in in a tube of
Dimensions w
and one those are these quantities and
so this this uh this difference between
normalizes it's controlled by this
square root uh product of these two
quantities divided by P times so times
this
final scale uh in words what does this
inequality mean is that well if the set
of points on the set of lines you start
with are not too concentrated then this
renormalized incidence count does not
change as you vary the scale too much
so it makes things these things are
small the error term is small
integration is not concentrated
um some words about the proof I won't
get too much into it it's a very
beautiful simple idea but it takes takes
some effort to uh to run this uh I
should say that maybe again the proof is
not not entirely new it's really a
combination of the rod argument and and
what what happens in good Solomon Wang
wrote perhaps curiously so being
interested in the hellborn Triangle
problem used in a quality like this an
L2 kind of type inequality like this to
lower bound incidences at a smaller
scale in terms of incidences at uh at
the bigger scale whereas good Solomon
Wang are interested in Upper bonds for
incidences
so they it's more it's a paper more in
the style of the usual uh
uh papers in
incidentally I study upper bonds for
incidences between points and tubes
um and this is an equality that kind of
captures both sides of the story so it's
both an upper and a lower bound at the
same time but of course like Roth we
really care about lower bounding this
quantity in terms of the the first one
so what's really the idea uh if you
stare long enough at this uh difference
it's really an inner product it's an
absolute value of an inner product uh
and they probably begin to functions so
this one function is kind of like uh the
sum of characteristic functions of the
points in p
however it's a bit a bit smoother and to
make the L2 Norm of this function small
in order to apply all these tools you
want to really small Norms uh so you
replace characteristic function of a
point with the characteristic function
maybe of a ball Center at that point
that has radius W final
um and the second function is this
difference in characteristic functions
so it's a sum over all the lines and L
and you're looking at a characteristic
function of a tube generated by L at
scale initial W initial minus the
characteristic function of the tube
generated by L at scale W final
renormalized appropriately
so that uh
these things are actually orthogonal
functions
so uh the the the the driving force
behind this is koshy javarts of course
uh this this inner product can be
controlled as follows and then the L2
Norm of G
is upper bounded by yes
uh it's a good question uh it's a good
question especially I think after our
paper because the the way we State we do
things is completely on the physical
side uh the correct answer is that this
inner product here actually uh so what
what this upper bound is doing can also
be reinterpreted on the physical on the
on the frequency side as a decomposition
between high frequencies and low
frequencies you can split this up uh it
has a natural for the analytic uh analog
after applying parts of violence so one
you don't really need this uh so one can
proceed with questions on the physical
side and then try to understand the L2
Norm of G and the L to Norm of uh Phi
separately the L2 Norm of G
will involve this ultimately MP the
maximum number of points at the final
scale and uh this uh this L2 normal Phi
will involve ML and this uh
understanding of the L2 Norm remember is
a bit more subtle this uses the
orthogonality of these functions
and uh this is where you have this high
frequency low frequency decomposition on
the on the previous side
on the physical side you just split in
terms of uh how large are the angles
between pairs of lines when you expand
this out the square of that
any other questions about the inductive
step I uh well
move on to the initial estimate
okay
uh okay so that's all I want to say
about the inductive so let me see some
things about the initial estimate so uh
this is where projection query comes in
so let me just hopefully get to that
um
so I'll describe some opening moves so
remember where our goal is to find small
area triangles and
we started with pairs of points at this
point we have two parameters to worry
about right pairs of points the
distances between Pairs of points and
Heights so widths of width of cubes and
kind of hard to control both at the same
time ensuring that both are small so uh
it's uh good to put one fix one from the
beginning so that you don't really
stress out uh about that uh as much for
the rest of the argument Roth Begins by
fixing widths of tubes
we proceed by fixing the parameter U so
the upper bound on the on the distances
between Pairs of points we can see there
in the line set so fix a mule and let's
partition uh the the square at as an
opening move uh into smaller U by U
squares access parallel okay and uh okay
here's a way to ensure that uh pairs of
points have distance at most you or if
you want U root two but we don't really
care that much about constants we will
only focus on sets of pairs of points
that uh that are in the same square so I
look at I look at e Square Q at the time
and I look at pairs of points there
they're close to each other and distance
and most here
so I have a picture like this I'll I
draw squares and through each pair of
points in the same square I draw this
cube of some width W sub I parameter
that I have to actually stress about now
um so what what will be this uh this
parameter W Supply I would like to pick
W Supply to be sufficiently large
compared to U
such that
um I can actually hope to find many
incidences between uh between these
tubes of this width and and um
and and the point in P so the tubes that
I'm considering again are the tubes that
have generating lines lines passing
through two points in the same square
and this is the the width that I'm
fixing W sub I and notice that okay if I
want an initial estimate so if I want
this uh the incidences between the
points and the tubes to be large as
expected it would be really nice if for
each
or if for for most tubes for most lines
in the union of of these line sets one
coming from each Square so for each line
in the picture it would be nice if the
number of points in the corresponding
tube is at least this W sub by times p
it will be really great because I then
can sum up the contribution for each
line and of course I don't care if if
it's just a constant proportion of the
lines uh that's still good to get a good
initialized
so I would like at least I bought some
large width that uh that uh can hope to
achieve something like this it won't be
easy but notice that because this width
is uh large compared to you if I try to
set things up this way then notice that
um
uh this uh uh this is really a
a problem about the directions of the
lines determined by these uh these
squares there so a tube like this is
really determined by the direction of
this line rather than how uh this
translation translational offset here uh
if you change if if you if you shift
this line a little bit you're gonna
still get the tube that has like huge
overlap with this tube this W sub I is
quite close close to you so this is
really ensuring this this lower bound on
this this is really a problem about
directions and uh so uh that's that
that's that's the first the first idea
perhaps one can reduce this uh initial
estimate problem defining a skill level
is a buy which we have an instance two a
problem about understanding the set the
direction span by these lines inside
these squares and indeed this possible
to to show that uh one can one can show
that for most squares in this picture
um there if you just focus on the
directions of the tubes now they're not
too many directions for these W Supply
tubes uh that contain few points
and so this is just an easy double
counting Mark if you forget if you zoom
out a little bit and forget about
directions of these lines and just think
about uh I have the square and I have
tubes containing the square and I claim
that for more squares there are not many
directions that have two points from the
configuration
um okay that's that's something we can
do however they're still possibly uh
directions where tubes have few points
and uh I have to really stress about
the possibility of my lines from lq
being concentrated in these bad
directions it could be that these there
are many good directions for tubes going
here going here that contain many points
from from q but uh
um many points from P but it could be
that
these directions are bad and most of the
lines are concentrating in those bad
directions
um so this can happen however uh it
doesn't happen if the intersection of p
with Q is an S dimensional set for SMS
strictly greater than one yes
I'll get to that in a second so uh this
is a different different argument sooner
sooner or later we'll see it will lead
to a different proof for the eight over
seven the way I'm stating things
it's a bit different than their uh
initial estimate so this is this is not
how they do their initial estimate at
all they start with tubes that have many
points and they struggle to find pairs
of points inside them that are close to
each other they kind of do the opposite
yes so this can be made uh precise uh so
the the key input is the smart strand
theorem that kind of uh is related to
the first theorem it's from the same
very the same paper from 54. so if you
have a set a barrel set in R2 that has
Dimensions strictly greater than one uh
then the set of directions so I think
about the direct radiant the directions
as points as on on the unit circle
uh this is the directions uh is full
dimensional so it's a subset of S1 it
definitely has Dimension at most one the
claim is that if the original set as I
mentioned bigger than one then the set
of Direction has Hoster Dimension equal
to one
um
so this is a continuous statement
we would like to use it for our
finite problem so uh and we reverse
engineer that story
from from the uh erdogman conjecture we
really need
this technology to serve the purposes of
finite problem red and so uh we kind of
use discretization
[Music]
um
to
borrow this uh what is uh
we need a definition so what what is the
discrete version of a s dimensional set
uh
if I give you a set of points Finance it
the points possibly uh you say that P is
as regular Above Scale Delta if the
following condition is satisfied for all
squares of length w
so the intersection of p with any W by W
square is controlled by this uh by this
right hand side expression and then
discrete version of marstrand says that
well if this intersection of P would
with the with the square in my my naive
partition from the beginning is as
regular for some s greater than one the
set of directions is quite spread out it
cannot really be like in the picture on
the left
so uh this means something along the
following lines if I count the number of
lines in lq that point into an interval
of directions I then it's at most the
constants times what you'd expect if the
lines would be random
um so this uh this is true for every
interval of directions of length least
Delta
here are some quick uh quick pictures I
want to have time to stare at them with
you uh so on the left you have a two
regular set my strength theorem here
tells you that the direction set so you
should draw pairs lines through pairs of
points and you look what are the
directions they're quite spread out and
hopefully it's believable if the picture
looks like this this is a one regular
set one dimensional set my strength
theorem in this case does not really say
anything perhaps it's not so easy to see
in this picture but there are of course
other much easier examples of
one-dimensional sets take points on the
line
um that's a one-dimensional set and it's
just one direction in that case the
direction set is Zero Dimensional you
cannot really say anything about the set
of directions of a one-dimensional state
you don't have any more hypotheses it
can be zero dimension
um okay so uh I'll describe quickly uh
how do you use this discretize my strand
uh kind of the the it's uh
we know what we're looking for now we
know that we really like U by U squares
for which the intersection is more than
one dimensional the intersection will be
more than one dimensional you cannot
really achieve this if you take a
careless partition of the of this the
original square with your Bayou squares
so you really want to do a more delicate
the composition into squares where the
intersections are one plus Epsilon
regular for some Epsilon the regularity
is also called frostman regularity
um and then using using this discrete by
my strand we get manual space lines in
the square in each set of lines coming
from the square and with well space
lines one can prove
uh an incidence lower bound
rather quickly
uh so any set of points you give me and
any
pens I give you uh
several pencils of lines where so you
have a set of lines through each point
in pi and the lines are well separated
according to a condition like the one we
saw something like that leads in
immediately to uh
the One initial estimate lower bound
I use different notation because this is
not the original config the original P
will consider and in fact
uh is not really uh they don't even have
to be necessarily points MP we have
remember we have these lines passing
through so we have these good squares uh
and some partition and we have lines
from uh
um so e Square determines the set of
lines they don't necessarily pass to the
same point but they're rather close
together so that we don't care about
incidence between points and lines we
care about instead between points and
tubes at some scale and if the scale
ETA is bigger than the the parameter U
for the side of the square then I can
assume I can pick this P for each Square
I can pick a point inside and I can
pretend all my lines from E Square are
actually passing through some single
point they are separated and uh I can
apply something like this I get an
initial lower Bound for uh at scale ETA
the same scale for which I have the
separation okay I won't really get into
numbers because I'm out of time the The
Twist that um
I was alluding to earlier uh when
answering Orion's question is that um
quite interesting initially
disappointing but quite interestingly uh
the stories so far only recovers the
eight over seven bounds it really gives
an alternative proof for the komalosh
pins summary the exponent
um
and uh
there's a very good reason why it it
reaches this eight over seven so uh I
promised I would tell you a bit about
how this 8 over 7 is a natural limit of
uh of Road strategy it is a limit of
this combination of
high low with the initial estimate
approach to finding small area triangles
so uh we have essentially two ways to
find small triangles in in this proof so
we have this initial estimate an
inductive strip strategy but remember
when you apply this high low upper Bond
you can apply we can go from one skill
to another if the points are not too
concentrated
so this is the error term is controlled
if the the the
the points are the points and lines are
not too concentrated if they are you
have to zoom in and find a small square
that contains three points so you're
kind of combine it with this this
inductive and in the spirit of density
increment type strategy
and uh uh if uh if
uh if the points original points are
well spaced so uh like for example the
set of points is homogeneous every every
uh every uh square of the these
Dimensions contains almost a constant
number of points so it's this points it
is two-dimensional roughly at all the
way up to all the way down to scale uh
one over root n then you can actually
bypass this eight over seven you can
find a triangle of area at most that
turns out this is not really the worst
case for the combination of these two
ways to find triangles so the worst case
turns out to be a two-dimensional setup
to some scale and uh and uh one
dimensional beyond that scale and if you
actually
write down what put some number here for
you and uh calculate what what should uh
what what what the triangle area with
with the with the hybrid situation like
this give it really recovers eight over
seven
um so I'll end by telling you the punch
line for uh getting a bit beyond eight
over seven so the main ingredient uh is
a remarkable recent theorem of pony
Merkin and one from uh December or
November last year they proved this
beautiful result right in time for us to
to use that
um
so they show that you can actually say
something about the set of directions of
a set of points that's less than one
dimensional if you assume that this set
of points is not contained on a line
like in the pathological case I
described
the set of directions uh well okay it's
either one like before or so if if
X has large Dimension or at least it has
Dimension at least the original
dimension
so this is a uh
a result that incorporates relies on
work against discretizing product
theorem in fact it relies on
uh generalization of the result for the
first time brexit problem that I
mentioned uh and and uh
a few other nice ideas it can also be
regarded as a continuous analog of a
really nice theorem over FP Sony's
theorem that if I take a set an FB
squared that has size at most B then it
contains at least this many distinct
directions so this is a theorem that
originally was proved by reday when a
has size p
uh and was unclear how to go below P for
a while and it's only uh prove the
result like this
uh so the point the point is really to
try to discretize this uh incorporate
sets that are below one dimensional and
uh try to use that information to get a
better initial estimate so to go to go
to smaller scales uh I won't uh
tell you about complications there are
several interesting yes technicalities
uh about how to actually use this uh
discretized formulation is not not not
so easy because of this uh what what
this hypothesis corresponds to in in the
discretized setting
but uh I I hope at least it gives you a
sense of how these things get together
it's all end here thank you
we don't know probably not uh it is an
important exponent for this problem
so it's a good question it's uh it's a
limit
in some sense a different limit for
respond to how much you can use the high
low this is inductive inductive step
below seven over six you would need to
somehow do something else or maybe
improve the high low estimate completely
new way
um probably it is not time though
what do you believe
yeah I think short answer is we don't
know we have this agreements about this
oh I think I believe that uh
the answer should Pro would be nice if
it's one over N squared again up to the
log
but I wouldn't be
they have
I believe it would be necessary if this
pick up yeah maybe it would be nicer
exactly
so lower bounds should be very problem
so we can't
any other questions
those are three or more dimensions so
this is a good question for Dima he
wrote the paper about this recently the
quantum bought several several uh
variants of this problem so I guess the
the more standard one you can ask
so there are some bounds known I think
for this problem Dimension demo approved
there's a tetrahedron of volume 1 over
into the four thirds
I think that's the there's no result one
can also prove what we can also
intermediate
still about
area of the smallest area triangles
that's a more subtle problem uh
[Music]
no non-trivial bounds are currently
known for that somehow just this
pigeonhole from the beginning is the
best working products
yes
those normal questions